si c'est parfois difficile de faire une
séparation stricte on passe à un autre
sujet les élections municipales c'est en
2020 c'est ça casse pas comme ça alors
on ne sait pas encore s'il vous gaz par
an
cette quantité à la mairie de paris mais
en tout cas il ya déjà quelques
candidats officiels à la république en
marche au moins deux ministres benjamin
griveaux et mounir mahjoubi plus un
député un sénateur quelques autres qui
hésite et s'il y avait en plus peut-être
pour les départager
edouard philippe le premier ministre y
en a qui trouvent que ce sera une très
bonne idée c'est cette grippe cédric
villani le député la république en
marche de l'essonne écoutez le je pense
qu'il ya eu des problèmes importants sur
la méthode qui justifie que la
république en marche présente un
candidat contre ann hidden away and
hidalgo qui me serait le bon profil on
parle d' edouard philippe le premier
ministre est pour l'instant et beaucoup
de noms qui circulent trop et doit
résister la solution edouard philippe
serait bien sûr un grand maire de paris
et j'en suis persuadé il a déjà été un
grand maire du havre alors gas travers
on a envie de vous entendre edouard
philippe ferait il un bon maire de paris
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas quelles
sont ses intentions pour l'instant il a
un job important quand même à remplir ce
qu'il gagne dès le premier ministre je
pense que ça doit suffire quand même mal
occuper totalement et je pense qu'il est
mauvais que un premier ministre des
ministres des membres du gouvernement ou
des députés pensent déjà à la prochaine
élection moi j'avais quelque chose que
j'ai bien aimé dans l'élection de mme
hélène macron c'était la promesse du
renouvellement politique ait l'idée
qu'on freine la politique autrement
je pense qu'une des clés pour faire la
politique autrement c'est de se
consacrer totalement au mandat ou à la
fonction qu'on vous a désigné qu'elle
est là quelle plus belle fonction que
premier ministre de la france après près
en république ça devrait suffire au
bonheur d'edouard philippe et je suis
certain parce que j'ai beaucoup d'estimé
pour lui ce que pense oui gérard collomb
pour la fonction de ministre de
l'intérieur à parce qu'il a tort
je pense qu'il a tort je pense que
gérard collomb devrait rester à son
poste jusqu'au bout là il ya une menace
terroriste importante il faut que se
consacrer pleinement à sa tâche
on peut pas tout faire à la fois
ministre premier ministre c'est déjà un
beau job il faut se concentrer
totalement et quand eux
quant aux élections à la mairie de paris
je prends ça sera aux parisiennes et aux
parisiens d'en décider
et oh vous savez qu habituellement ils
n'aiment pas trop qu'on se sert de paris
comme un marchepied un tremplin une
médaille
et il ya ceux qui ont été parachutés de
l'extérieur pour être conduit la mairie
de paris n'ont pas conservé des
bons souvenirs puisqu'il s'appelle
d'ornano séguin nkm joxe sont tous du
essuyé une sévère défaite
et bien voilà premier ministre prévenu
on vous pose la question à vous chers
internautes d'après vous edouard
philippe ferait il un bon maire pour la
ville de paris vous êtes 62% répondre
non à 38%
oui pour cherain sur twitter edouard
philippe à gérer la ville du havre c'est
une ville importante
ses compétences de près ministre
serviront beaucoup et edouard philippe
remplit toutes les conditions requises
bon bah celui là est fan de toute
évidence et vous anne sophie beauvais
non mais ça l'est pour le coup je suis
vraiment d'accord avec avec gaspar noé
heures je pense que edouard philippe a
effectivement les premiers mise de la
france et il doit être consacré à sa
tâche moi je trouve ça quand même fou
que deux ans avant une élection on parle
autant des candidats potentiels à 7 à
cette élection et effectivement ils sont
très nombreux
renouvellement de la classe politique
oui en même temps ce renouvellement de
la classe politique
il ré avec un ancrage un petit peu plus
fort sur un terrain localement je trouve
que ce serait pas une mauvaise chose je
pense notamment aux députés élus
en marche parce que je moi j'étais pour
qu'on limite les mandats dans le temps
mais peut-être pas qu'on déconnecte
complètement le mandat de député avec
celui de maire parce que je pense qu'on
apprend beaucoup d'un territoire et que
d'une certaine manière que certains
députés et un ancrage local un petit peu
plus important je serai plus que nos
ministres qui effectivement est une
tâche lourde après pour la mairie de
paris
moi je suis banlieusarde et donc j'avoue
que si on pouvait avoir un futur maire
de paris qui n'est pas une vision
égoïste de paris mais qu'il à tourner un
peu vers la banlieue je suis pas valérie
pécresse par exemple aujourd'hui un
discours en tout cas qui réconcilie un
petit peu les banlieusards avec paris je
regarde mon partenaire de noyon saison
passée ce message je suis votre droite
une fois votre bouche mais le je suis
très attaché à ces questions je pense
que le prochain maire de paris doit être
le maire du grand paris tout simplement
alors il ya quelqu'un une autre personne
qui serait assez favorable à la
candidature d'edouard philippe c'est un
hamac les céistes qui interview au
figaro quotidien de deux ans
et voilà donc un hamac sera donne en
interview dans le figaro demain et je
vous l'annonçais en avant première il
considère qu' edouard philippe serait le
meilleur candidat pour paris d'autant
ajoute-t-il qui serait capable de faire
alliance avec la droite modérée génie
bastille est votre avis sur ce sujet oui
ça c'est significatif qu il ya autant de
gens dans le gouvernement macro qui
veulent devenir maire de paris ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses aussi sur ce
qu'est le maquereau nisme puisque on
pourrait presque mettre une égalité
entre macro nice mais paris puisque mais
le maquereau a fait 90 % à la
présidentielle au 2e tour à paris
et c'est quand même la fin qu'on dit je
parle de paris un pas de paris et de sa
banlieue mais paris c'est quand même la
ville de décomposer plutôt d'une
bourgeoisie soit libéral soit de droite
ou de gauche qui s'est réconcilié dans
le maquereau nisme et voilà par bribes
paris est aussi le symbole de cela et
donc je pense que n'importe quel
candidat dans marche n'aurait aucune
difficulté à gagner paris même si
évidemment il y a
il ya une particularité à paris c'est
que c'est comme aux états unis
on peut avoir on peut ne peuvent ne pas
avoir la majorité des voix mais gagner
quand même la mairie taille puisque ce
sont les arrondissements finalement
enfin c'est quand on dirait du dandysme
ans qui choisissent les maires de paris
donc ça peut être comme aux états unis
on peut faire basculer les
arrondissements qui ont fait basculer
les étapes pourra regagner paris donc ça
change un peu la donne
mais cela dit je crois que en marche à
un tapis rouge à paris s'il veut gagner
après la la mairie alors vous le disiez
il ya beaucoup de candidats en marche
mais il y en a aussi pas mal ailleurs
même marcel campion et candidat à la
mairie de paris
et pour cause parce que ce job tout le
monde en rêve c'est en tout cas la
conviction de rachida dati qui est maire
du 7e arrondissement et qui était invité
ce matin de notre ami yves thréard dans
le talk du figaro
aujourd'hui qu'elle est lille paris qui
ne rêve pas du mandat de maire de paris
tous celui qui vous dit non il ment
parce que c'est un très beau mandat
c'est la plus belle ville du monde moi
je considère il ya beaucoup d'enjeu et
des enjeux très intéressant c'est grâce
à tout le monde en rêve même vous moi je
ne rêve pas pour moi j'aurais de paris
depuis toujours donc maintenant être à
la mairie paris pour continuer à rêver
cette ville mais je pense que c'est
surtout les pailles sont surtout les
parisiennes et les parisiens qui ont
envie de rêver de nouveau de leur ville
ils sont moins contents quand quand même
de sécurité propreté de logement de
transport et surtout peut-être que leur
vie de bree moins dans le monde
les artistes du monde entier ne se bat
plus pour venir à paris comme à l'époque
des mines ou et c'est bien dommage les
entreprises du monde entier ne se bat
plus pour venir à paris c'est bien
dommage et c'est ça qu'il faut retrouver
notamment renaud girard fait nous le
portrait robot du meilleur maire de
paris en tout cas c'est pas selon moi
edouard philippe pas qu'il en ait pas
pas qu'il en ait pas les capacités
on a certainement les capacités et
peut-être même le goût mais qui je pense
qu'il doit préférer le havre puisqu'on
était maire mais j'ose assez grave comme
signe des temps si vous voulez il nous a
annoncé enfin emmanuel macron et lui
nous ont annoncé la fin après un
discours de politique générale
edouard philippe il a voilà et le
gouvernement dit la constitution
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation
l'article 20 de la constitution alors il
nous il a dit qu'il allait réformer le
pays
on attend on attend edouard philippe
pour le moment il a fait un budget
extrêmement timide extrêmement mou sans
vouloir déplaire à gaspard extrêmement
hollandais voilà et elle a pris du recul
n'y a pas de problème aux landais voilà
alors pas du tout dans la ligne de ce
que nous avait annoncé alors je pense je
pense que ça serait ça serait dingue il
a il a une tâche a fait alors on dit il
prend son temps il veut prendre son
temps c'est très bien en tout cas on lui
donne cinq ans pour vraiment réformer la
france
on espère que quand il rendra son
tablier deux premiers ministres et un
tablier
n'est ce pas extrêmement important en
l'occurrence plus important que celui de
maire de paris
edel qui nous donne une france en bien
meilleur état qu'il l'a trouvé
je pense qu'il faut qui continue son
travail il allait avec un premier
ministre tout à fait compétent alors
après en politique c'est comme repris
dans mâcon c'est la volonté qui comptait
y l'intelligencia la connaissance de
l'administration et après il ya le vent
t il ya le courage pour le moment ils en
ont montré un peu pas énormément on les
attend mais mais mais cette espèce de
zapping dans les fonctions politiques et
dangereux et je dirais même un drame de
notre démocratie de notre pays
deux réactions d'internautes à ces
critiques vincent qui trouvent que le
premier ministre a déjà suffisamment
abîmé le havre et la france quant à j lr
il considère qu' edouard philippe s'est
déjà mis la majorité des français à dos
avec le 80 km heure c'est un argument
qui revient souvent à contretemps avec
jean-philippe impossible qu'il soit élu
maire de la capitale nous affirme jlr
jeudi bastié oui alors moi je pense que
c'est pas difficile de faire mieux qu
hidalgo en matière de propreté de
sécurité d'entretien du patrimoine à
paris
par contre et ça je pense que quelqu'un
en marche en tout cas sera plus
pragmatique
en revanche il ya une question qui est
un vrai problème à paris
l'action la mixité sociale et du prix du
logement qui s'envole et si c'est pour
faire de paris encore plus la capitale
des csp + et finalement ne rien faire
pour lutter par exemple contre la
propagation d'airbnb parce que voilà en
marche c'est aussi sont les héros de la
libéralisation de l'économie et si on ne
fait rien contre
airbnb contre le fait que finalement on
a vu l'a récemment qu' il ya plus de
milliardaires aujourd'hui à paris qu'il
y en a à londres après corexit 6,6 enfin
si le seul but c'est de faire de paris
une capitale attractive pour les
capitaux et donc pour les millionnaires
moi je trouve que c'est pas suffisant
pour les parisiens parce que s'il ya
quand même une un enjeu de mixité
sociale à paris qui devient très
problématique puisque à part certains
quartiers nord où il ya une très forte
immigration il n'y a plus de classes
populaires à paris il n'ya plus même
même plus de classes moyennes à paris
il n'y a plus de famille et je trouve
que c'est un enjeu très important donc
savez moi j'ai je suis père de quatre
enfants et je vous dirais que c'est un
exploit pour les familles que l'on
croise vendant pari de rester dans paris
intra muros
je vais totalement dans le sens de ce
que denis bastien parce que vraiment il
faut qu'on se batte pour qui les classes
populaires et de questions une caresse
lens et lille et que ça devienne pas la
ville de la spéculation immobilière
comme elle l'est aujourd'hui par exemple
je suis pas du tout sûr que ce soit une
bonne idée qu'on se bat pour que tous
les anglais ou les financiers qui sont à
la city revient à paris pour faire
exploser les prix de l'immobilier
je pense que non mais c'est un mais
qu'est ce que c'est ce qui est en train
de se passer notamment avec moi j'ai pas
du tout envie que les londoniens restent
à londres vraiment je ne souhaite pas du
tout qui y viennent nous faire monter
les prix partout dans paris
il faut construire des logements sociaux
conçoit des logements intermédiaires
évidemment réguler extrêmement fortement
les herbes emba consoeurs qui font
exploser les prix de l'immobilier aussi
à l'achat comme à la vente et même à la
location et puis certainement aussi
construit une politique du logement
intelligente à l'échelle de nous en
parlerons parlais tout à l'heure
parce que cette ville est beaucoup trop
petit on est une ville qui est cernée
par son périphérique et qui à moins de 5
km de son centre
c'est la ville la plus petite du monde
dans les grandes capitales il suffit
d'aller à madrid à berlin à rome à
londres à tokyo je prends même pas tokyo
new york ça pour se rendre compte qu'on
est une ville minuscule et c'est la
source de beaucoup de nos problèmes
anne-sophie pauvres on raisonne l'afp
quelques minutes comme si ali d'algos
n'allait pas être réduits et pourtant il
lui reste en fait en tout cas c'est ce
qu'on dira ce que jacques tord à la
réelle malgré toutes ces critiques ça ça
vous surprendre oui et puis enfin
et puis lui reste surtout deux ans moi
je me mets à sa place d'une
p'tain manière deux ans est encore
longue à l'échelle d'une ville
et donc je me pose des questions sur sa
capacité j'allais dire à faire que
pendant ces deux ans des décisions
puissent être encore prises dans de
bonnes conditions avec cette
effervescence autour de la mère de bari
moi je partage pas du tout là
enfin jaillir la vision d'un maire de
paris pour ça pour sa ville et je le
redis je trouve qu'il ya eu un problème
d'abord de un peu d'enfermement de paris
sur elle même par rapport à la par
rapport à la banlieue je pense qu'il ya
eu aussi un problème de méthode puisque
elle décide de fermer par exemple les
voies sur berge sans concertation une
concertation qui est enclenchée après
coup et que ça a provoqué quand même bon
nombre de problèmes notamment sur ses
périphéries que gaspard grandeur veut
supprimer mais pour le moment c'est
quand même là où la circulation a été a
été repoussé et puis toutes ces voix en
30 sur paris qui sont aujourd'hui
complètement bouché mais malgré tout ce
que je les reconnais c'est une vision
pour la ville de paris c'est à dire
qu'elle est on a tendance à l'oublier
quand même aussi un tout petit peu on
lui tape dessus tous comme des sourires
elle a une vraie vision une vision
écologique pour ça pour sa ville
donc et elle a essayé avec courage
malgré tout parce que vu son niveau
d'impopularité on veut pas lui dénier sa
de la m de la mettre en oeuvre
voilà non mais c'est une vision malgré
tout qui ce qui peut se défendre elle un
cap
voilà le paradoxe est en commun le
paradoxe étant quand même qu'on a
reporté donc la pollution sur le
périphérique et vous savez l'endroit le
plus pollué de paris le mettrons donc il
ya comme un petit problème c'est que
quand on construit une politique contre
la pollution pour l'environnement ce qui
est très juste et ce qu'il faut faire il
faut le faire de façon cohérente avec la
bonne méthode
alors